We’re talking about discovering
life on another planet.
It’ll change our concept
of who we are...
Where we came from...
And where we’re going.
♪♪
In season 3 of For All Mankind,
we’re jumping almost 10 years
into our history timeline.
It’s now the 90’s
an era with a huge
explosion of technology.
We have bases on the moon,
we have a hotel in orbit...
The space race is booming.
And you start to
see space tourism.
And the idea of reaching
further into space
is the main
driving force
in the race to Mars.
The whole world waits to see
who will land first.
We’re living in a world
where getting to
Mars is a possibility
and it’s a race between
superpowers: NASA,
the Soviets,
and now a company called Helios.
We will propel this
one-of-a-kind
spacecraft
on an epic journey
of exploration...
to Mars.
Helios is a private company
and truly wants to do
something groundbreaking.
♪♪
You are going up against the two
most powerful nations
in the world.
All of these different
groups are going
head-to-head to get
to Mars first,
and the politics of the Cold War
are now much
more complicated.
Because their
commitment and dedication
has spanned three decades,
it takes an already
high stakes situation
and makes it even
higher stakes.
The US of A is
gonna win this race.
There's a sense that, that
competition brings
everyone together.
The future...
Belongs to all of us!
This can support large
scale human colonization.
This race to Mars is definitely
just the tip of the iceberg.
We will see them begin
to establish a new colony
like the early settlers
start a new Jamestown.
And we see all the
difficulties and challenges
and the sacrifices
it takes to get there.
Our mission is to create a
sustainable base and survive.
Oh my God.
And the idea of
what we can do,
and where we
can go from here.
To be explorers, and
things that make us
better as human beings
and do great things.
That's what's gonna push mankind
to make the next leap forward:
colonizing Mars and
the Moons of Saturn.
What if this is our chance?
Space truly is
the final frontier.
Human beings are
always gonna wanna see....
What's over that next hill?
It's only the beginning.